And without further ado,...
...Mrs. Daughtry, would you like to present the MVP trophy for the American League?
Koji, this award is for you.
Koji Uehara was responsible in four of the wins in this series.
He won one game and he saved three and he struck out nine batters.
We're all very proud of you.
Kaz, join your dad.
I wanted to ask, what was it about this year that made Koji so dominant?
All the credit goes to the staff, the players that supported me.
What kind of pressure was on him every single night?
Jon Lester told me after game five...
...he was biting his nails when he was on the mound pulling for this guy.
What pressure did he feel?
To tell you the truth, I almost threw up.
Kaz, let me ask you, your dad says he almost threw up out there.
How did you feel when he was pitching?
I don't know.
You don't know?
Did you get sick when he was out there or were you excited?
Excited.